dernière le premier ministre jean castex
est bien affirmée qui est de lutter avec
fermeté contre l'islamisme radical après
l'attentât de conflans sainte honorine
est ce que vous le faites confiance dans
cette action je crois que dans ce moment
où la concorde nationale est nécessaire
il faut faire confiance aux pouvoirs
exécutifs faire confiance à ne pas dire
être dans une sorte de béatitude à son
égard il faudra être critique et vous
savez moi j'ai appartenu à un
gouvernement qui a dû faire face à des
attentats bien plus important
malheureusement et on avait demandé au
travers notamment du discours à la
semaine nationale de manuel valls eu la
confiance de l'assemblée du parlement en
général donc j'ai envie de dire oui
simplement on voit bien quand même les
limites de l'exercice
et qu'il y à beaucoup aujourd'hui
d'annonce un petit peu en réaction
immédiate à l'attentât sur les
expulsions sur la fermeture d'une
mosquée sur la dissolution
d'associations
la vraie question c'est aujourd'hui il y
avait plein d'outils juridiques
disponibles pour pour l'état pourquoi
n'avons pas nous utiliser précédemment
ce type d'outil donc selon vous on a été
laxiste vis-à-vis de certaines
associations et certaines mosquées
je vais en passer je n'utiliserais pas
le mot de laxiste je pense qu'il faut
mettre sous surveillance les mouvements
salafistes je disais récemment à la au
plateau de la haute assemblée qu'il n'y
a jamais de mots de fondamentalisme a
jamais tranquille il n'y a jamais de
salafisme à jamais je dirais tranquille
aussi par rapport à la population il ya
toujours des risques de débordements
mais la radicalisation qui n'est pas un
as dit aujourd'hui d'être surveillés par
les pouvoirs de police pour éviter que
cela déborde la violence alors
aujourd'hui les motifs notamment pour
fermer des associations et des mosquées
eh bien ce sont l'appel à la haine à la
violence
est ce que l'idéologie salafiste en tant
que tel peut être un nouveau motif pour
fermer une association masquer le
salafisme en tant que telle n'est pas un
délit je me permets de le dire tu peux
être choqué en disant cela
ce qui est un délit c'est le passage à
la violence et à l'atteinte ou alors de
la république et au meurtre en
l'occurrence au travers de ce qui s'est
passé à l'encontre terriblement de de ce
professeur d'histoire et géographie
samuel pâtit dans ce cadre moi ce que je
souhaite c'est renforcer les moyens
encore une fois de la police des
renseignements généraux
paru à une autre époque mais aujourd'hui
retrait sous une autre forme et qui
permettront finalement de surveiller par
contre il est évident que tous les
ennemis de la république qui veulent
faire passer la loi religieuse avant la
loi de la république doit pouvoir d'une
manière ou d'une autre notamment quand
ils sont étranges et pouvoir être
expulsé mais l'expulsion n'est pas aussi
simple qu'on le pense il faut que le
pays d'accueil il accepte il faut ce
qu'on appelle des laissez passer
consulaires donc la volonté oui sachez
que dans un état de droit comme le nôtre
et bien certains profitent de cet état
de droit pour se protéger mais je ne
fais pas d'amalgamé
comme j'ai pu entendre trop souvent
aujourd'hui dans sexy dans l'actualité
entre immigration salafisme et
terrorisme non quand nous accueillons
des demandeurs d'asile qui fuient des
régimes terroristes islamistes
il faut savoir le faire dans de bonnes
conditions autre question
[Musique]